pas facile hein de m'avoir mis passé
derrière serge alors moi je vais vous
parler de sérendipité
alors je vous explique pas tout de suite
ce terme pour ceux qui le connaissent
pas bon je vous rassure tout de suite à
moi j'ai appris ce qu'était la
sérendipité au cours de cette aventure
je vais vous parler donc de sérendipité
qui comme vous le verrez illustre assez
bien les ricochets et 7 sérendipité a
abouti à une forme de recyclage
comment un vieux médicament qu'on avait
depuis 50 ans s'est avéré efficace pour
traiter une pathologie à quelle maladie
chez les enfants pour laquelle déjà
d'une part on n'avait pas de deux
traitements et puis surtout ça a été un
effet inattendu qu on a pu constater
sous nos yeux
comment à l'ère de la médecine moderne
où on greffe des visages on implante des
coeurs artificiels
finalement on peut encore juste en
regardant les patients en observant ce
qui se passe
avoir la chance de tomber sur une
observation qui nous a permis de mettre
au point un traitement efficace pour des
nourrissons donc dans une affection pour
laquelle on n'avait pas de traitement
vraiment qui marchait bien et l'ironie
quand même de cette histoire c'est que
juste une observation d'impatience et
substituer complètement à des mois voire
des années de recherche
on a parlé juste avant du temps qu'il
avait fallu pour mettre au point une
enzyme 15 ans puis finalement donc des
joueurs ont fini par trouver la solution
rapidement et bien là finalement c'est
juste l'observation du patient qui nous
a permis
mettre au point ce traitement et ça a
remplacé dix ans quinze ans de
développement alors en revenir au début
pourquoi avoir fait médecine alors je
vais sûrement vous décevoir un peu
souvent quand on demande aux médecins
pourquoi pourquoi vous avez fait
médecine quand as tu décidé de faire
médecine
souvent les médecins disent rats depuis
toujours j'ai voulu faire médecine pour
soigner les gens pour sauver le monde
c'était pas du tout mon cas je suis pas
du tout issu d'une famille d'un milieu
médical
j'ai passé un bac scientifique
mon père était prof de maths physique
chimie
donc autant vous dire je n'ai pas le
choix et muni de ce bac guillot hors de
question que je fasse des maths sup
intro médecine c'est vrai que si je vais
apprendre plein de choses intéressantes
c'est vrai que le fonctionnement du
corps humain
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
vraiment fascinant alors donc j'ai fait
médecine pourquoi avoir choisi la
dermatologie et la dermatologie
c'est une peu une sous spécialité il ya
même des gens qui pensent qu'on n'a pas
fait médecine non je racontais anecdote
je vois une petite fille en consultation
que je suis pour des engelures aux mains
des taches rouges sur la peau et en la
déshabillant le moment médias depuis ce
matin elle a des boutons qui sont
apparues donc je regarde elle avait ce
qu'on appelle magnifique roséole
infantile tout à fait typique jeu qui
écoutait c'est une roséole elle me
regarde
samedi projet amène chez le médecin bon
donc ça et c'est vous dire quand même
bon alors on a aussi nos collègues aussi
ont une vision de la dermatologie et
vous savez bon c'est un peu de la
bobologie à nous soigne pas le on sauve
pas le monde à chaque instant par contre
dès qu'ils ont un bouton n'importe quoi
ils savent pas ce que c'est il s'appelle
tout de suite il faut les voir dans
l'instant on appelle ça le cancer de la
peau qui est apparue juge le vendredi
soir donc il faut les voir pour les
rassurer tout de suite surtout si le
bouton est mal placée bien évidemment
alors pourquoi la dermato parce que bon
la dermatologie ce même spécialité large
celle enveloppe et ça dit beaucoup de
choses et c'est une spécialité
passionnante
alors pourquoi les enfants ce que vont
mes collègues jouer les enfants est
d'abord ils disent parce qu'ils ont ça
pleure ce pénible mais bon les enfants
il faut composer avec l' angoisse des
parents c'est ça qui est le plus
difficile en pédiatrie
vous êtes sûrement par an pour certains
d'entre vous savez que tout ce qui
touche à l'enfant dès que votre enfant
est malade ça génère un stress terrible
donc il faut quelqu'un quand même d'un
peu solide en face sinon on s'en prend
plein alors moi j'aime les travailler
que les enfants parce que les enfants
c'est positif
les enfants ce dès qu'ils vont bien ils
vont bien on les a guéri bon les adultes
sai on les soigne mais bon toujours oui
docteur à mieux mais quand même j'ai
encore si encore sabres les enfants les
enfants ça va bien ça va bien tout
démarre alors on en vient à l'histoire
quand même donc justement soignant ses
enfants on les soigne assez souvent dans
le service s'appelle l'année manger home
du nourrisson d'ailleurs c'est un truc
un peu bizarre ya rien à la naissance et
puis tout d'un coup dans les semaines
qui suivent à se développer une espèce
de boules rouges sur la peau du
nourrisson et cette boule elle va
grossir la taille d'une fraise des bois
frais espagnol voire même encore pire
et puis elles valent ce calme et puis
elle va rentrer dans l'ordre tout seul
va à le voir régresser
donc quand c'est une petite boule rouge
qui se forme on rassure les parents ne
vous inquiétez pas ça va diminuer tout
seul ça va rentrer dans l'ordre en fait
rien mais parfois ça peut être vraiment
dramatique ça peut être énorme gêner la
vision gêné l'enfant pour respirer est
là et bien il va falloir faire un
traitement mais c'est ce qui nous est
arrivé
donc on avait un enfant qui avait
vraiment un énorme angiome du nez avec
les complications et donc le traitement
qu'on utilise et jusqu'il ya peu c'était
la cortisone donc la cortisone sèchement
ce que c'est ça donne quand même
beaucoup d'effets secondaires et parmi
les effets secondaires donc il ya des
hypertensions des troubles cardiaques et
ce bébé a développé un problème
cardiaque
son coeur s'est mis à battre très vite
devenir très gros
donc le cardiologue a eu la bonne idée
de traiter cet enfant avec un médicament
qui s'appelle du propranolol donc sept
enfants étaient hospitalisés n'avaient
pas bien on lui donne le traitement et
le lendemain matin en passant à la
visite
ces pensionnés haut qu'est ce qui s'est
passé l'angiome avait la boule c'est
venu tout petit tout ratatiner avait
changé de couleur qu'on a arrêté la
cortisone
quelques temps après on a eu le bébé
vous voyez en photos vraiment une
évolution dramatique ce petit bébé petit
poids de naissance un triplé et donc on
a donné de la cortisone à ce bébé
malgré la cortisone sakrozy c'est ça
continue à grossir son oeil était
complètement fermée enfin c'était moins
une situation difficile
donc les autres traitements qu'on
proposait à l'époque tes médicaments
vraiment toxique
donc j'ai dit à mon collègue on discute
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
j'écoute on a eu un bébé juste avant on
avait vraiment eu l'impression que ce
propranolol y avait un effet sur l'enjeu
sommes donc plus le coeur de ce bébé
commencer un petit peu fatigué donc on
décide de le mettre sous propranolol et
là on avait laissé une maman en larmes
et une semaine après il revient que son
bébé dans le cosi et avec le sourire aux
lèvres on osait à peine le regard des
uns et la il ouvrait son oeil tout seul
donc conseillé lassés par hasard il ya
vraiment quelque chose qui se passe il
faut qu'on aille plus loin et c'est
comme ça que ça a démarré alors c'est ça
qu'on appelle la sérendipité
c'est à dire vous êtes parti pour
chercher quelque chose
et puis finalement vous tombez sur tout
autre chose mais qui s'avère peut-être
même encore plus intéressant que ce
qu'ils avaient au départ alors un autre
exemple de sérendipité est quand même
assez célèbre c'est un médicament c'est
le sildénafil alors peut-être ça vous
dit rien mais le nom commercial c'est le
viagra donc des patients ont été traités
pour des problèmes d'hypertension avec
du viagra et il y avait beaucoup de
passions qu'en redemander
donc c'est là les médecins se sont dit
bon il ya quelque chose là qu'il faut
creuser
bon la suite vous la connaissez alors ça
aurait pu s'arrêter là ça aurait pu être
un coup d'éclat mais tombée dans l'eau
et heureusement il ya eu un formidable
mouvement de solidarité on a été
soutenue vraiment par nos instances par
l'université par l'hôpital
il ya eu un dépôt de brevet et il ya un
industriel qui a développé le médicament
pour les enfants il ya très peu de
médicaments qui sont faits pour les
enfants pas si vous savez pas ce que
c'est décide pas un marché qui intéresse
énormément les industriels et puis c'est
difficile à faire des études chez des
tout petits bébés qu'on soit en moins de
six mois c'est pas évident et donc au
début
et d'ailleurs c'est pour la plupart des
médicaments comme ça qu'est ce qu'on
fait on prend des médicaments qu'on a
pour les adultes ont les bricoles on les
écrase on les pilons les dilue ce qui
veut dire que c'est quand même parfois
des sources d'erreurs et une
acceptabilité qui en général très
mauvaise avec des préparations et pèse
qui vont pas être bien prise par les
enfants ou bien des préparations condé
goût absolument ignobles et donc faire
prendre un petit nourrisson un produit
qu'un goût ignoble on n'y arrive pas et
donc là il ya vraiment eu un mouvement
formidable et donc on a passé toutes les
étapes et donc maintenant on a depuis
cette année un propranolol spécialement
fait pour les petits nourrisson avec
tout ce qui va avec c'est le graal le
l'autorisation de mise sur le marché
mais surtout toutes les conseils pour
les prescripteurs pour les parents
comment faut utiliser le traitement ce
qu'on peut en attendre
alors la morale de cette histoire c'est
que bon d'une part comme je voulais dis
donc c'est un médicament qui était
ancien propres à nos lol ça faisait 50
ans peu près qu'on le connaissait
mais il a fallu passer toutes les étapes
des agences de médicaments je vous parle
les dossiers à faire ça a été très long
ça a pris sept ans pour un médicament
qu'on connaissait déjà en les
industriels lui trouve
très court parce que le développement
d'un médicament c'est 10 ans 15 ans la
en sept ans on a bouclé la fermer
souvenez vous que c'est un médicament
qu'on connaissait déjà
donc ces temps de débats de ric hochet
entre les différents intervenants pour
aboutir à ce résultat
et puis surtout ce que je voulais faire
passer c'est que bon moi je suis là
aujourd'hui pour vous parler de ce
projet mais il faut savoir que ça a été
un travail d'équipé absolument
formidable et que sans tout ce travail d
équipe tous les gens qui se sont
mobilisés autour de ce projet pour qu'il
aboutisse
eh bien ça aurait été un coup d'éclat
mais il n'y aurait pas eu de ric hochet
je vous remercie